[موسيقى]
البطاريات تأتي بجميع الأشكال والأحجام بدءًا
من AAA التي تستخدمها في
جهاز التحكم عن بعد الخاص بك إلى أيون الليثيوم
والسيارات، والآن توجد
تقنية البطاريات الحرارية الخاصة بنا، وهذا في
الأساس منتج يسمح لنا
بتحويل الطاقة المتجددة مثل
الكهرباء من الرياح  وتحويل الطاقة الشمسية
إلى طاقة موثوقة للمستخدمين الصناعيين، شركة
antor Energy هي الشركة التي تقوم
ببناء هذه
البطاريات الضخمة، لذلك يعد هذا جزءًا من
منشأة التصنيع الخاصة بشركة anor، حيث تقوم الوحدات بتخزين
الطاقة مع حرارة تصل إلى درجات حرارة تصل إلى
11500 درجة مئوية، وهذا ما يحدث بشكل أساسي
داخل محمصة الخبز الخاصة بك، حيث تقوم بتشغيل
الكهرباء  من خلال ملف
وتسخن، نحن نفعل ذلك على
نطاق أوسع وفي درجات حرارة أعلى
ويمكنك القيام بذلك
بطريقة يمكنك من خلالها توصيل تلك
الطاقة المخزنة إما كحرارة مباشرة أو
كالكهرباء إلى
عميل صناعي عند الطلب مع قيام الشركة
بتوسيع نطاق فتح منشأة تصنيع جديدة،
الأمل هو أن التكنولوجيا الخاصة بهم يمكن أن تساعد في
حل مشكلة عالمية حرجة تتمثل في
تلوث الهواء الصناعي، حيث يوجد
عدم تطابق بين انقطاع
الرياح والطاقة الشمسية الذي يستمر و  بعيدًا
عن الطقس واحتياجات
المصنع الذي يكون تحت الطلب على مدار الساعة طوال أيام الأسبوع،
لذا تمتص تقنية البطاريات الحرارية لدينا
تلك الكهرباء المتقطعة
من الرياح والطاقة الشمسية
وتوفر الطاقة المستخدمة على مدار الساعة بدون
انبعاثات وفقًا
لوكالة الطاقة الدولية
القطاع الصناعي مسؤول عن
حوالي
25% من انبعاثات ثاني أكسيد الكربون. التكنولوجيا
والابتكار التي
يمكن أن تساعد في تقليل الغازات الدفيئة
ستحتل مركز الصدارة في مؤتمر Cop 28 في دولة
الإمارات العربية المتحدة. لم يتم إنشاء Cop
لمجتمع التكنولوجيا والابتكار
بشكل صحيح وهكذا من ناحية أخرى.  أعتقد أن
جمهور التكنولوجيا والابتكار هو
الوافد الجديد إلى حد ما على التكنولوجيا،
وسيتعين عليه أن يلعب دورًا هائلاً
جنبًا إلى جنب مع سياسة تغيير السلوك
وما إلى ذلك، وهذا ما تأمل شركة Entor Energy في
طرحه على الطاولة، وسنكون في شرطي
هذا العام وتاريخيًا
كان يُنظر إلى الصناعات الثقيلة على أنها من الصعب
إزالة الكربون منها، ونحن نريد حقًا أن نظهر
للعالم أن هناك طريقة يمكننا من خلالها القيام بذلك
باستخدام التقنيات والمنتجات
الموجودة اليوم والتي تكون فعالة من حيث التكلفة
للتغلب على الوقود الأحفوري، حيث أن Cop 28 يحتضن
أحدث التقنيات التي نأمل في
تحويلها  السماء الصناعية الرمادية والدخانية
إلى آفاق خضراء نابضة بالحياة تمهد
الطريق لمستقبل أنظف وأكثر
استدامة
[موسيقى]